So we've discussed interim memory, working memory and long-term memory, such as
episodic or semantic memory. But how do we get information to our long-term
memory? Well, there are four steps to long-term memory formation. There's
encoding, consolidation, storage and retrieval. Let's first start by looking at
encoding. So the first out of the four steps of turning information into
long-term memory, as we said, is encoding. This means that we attend to new
information, we take it in, and then we process the new information. So, our
brain focuses on something new, takes it in, and we process that information.
That is us encoding new information. Now the key here is attend. It's important
to remember that we have to pay attention. Attention is what drives the process
of encoding. That is we have to pay attention to and be aware of the
information that we are trying to remember. Now, there are two types of
encoding. One type of encoding is termed automatic processing. As the name
implies, it refers to encoding information that occurs with little effort or
conscious attention to the task. Remember, at the beginning of the lesson, when
we asked if you remembered what you had for breakfast. This is an example of
the kind of automatic processing we're talking about. So although you may have
encoded what you had for breakfast this morning, by the evening you may have
forgotten it. Because it took little effort or conscious attention to the task
the second type of encoding for long term memory is termed, effortful
processing. Effortful processing happens when we carefully pay attention to
information and try to make a conscious effort to remember the information. For
example, the type of symantic memories we have, such as remembering the names
of the presidents of the United States. Or trying to remember the names of all
the continents. These involve our ability to consciously pay attention to
information and to put an effort into retaining this information. While you
take notes for this class. Or watch our videos, you're engaging in effortful
processing because you're trying to retain the information that you've learned.
At least I hope so. So, how do we go about engaging in effortful processing?
Psychologists theorize levels of processing relate to our ability to more
deeply encode information so that our recall improves. Let's go into a little
more detail about this.